you asked me for sources one country
that has better net results for human
freedom and human rights by restricting
speech what's your source one time for
the latest installment of change my mind
unedited conversations on controversial
topics providing an opportunity to
rationalize one's own position as always
comment below with the topics you most
like to see in the future today we
revisit a controversial topic in hate
speech so it was perfectly fitting that
we revisited our most controversial
location Texas Christian University not
given the largely productive and mostly
civil nature of the last installment
I've changed my mind at TCU that the
school not only condemned our setup on
public property claiming it to have
literally adversely affected the health
of the student body but the school even
went as far as to offer counseling to
students who might have been faced with
the trauma of someone politely
expressing a difference of opinion so to
prove that the students are more robust
than the administrators and they're
tweeters give them credit for we had to
go back only this time if we were asked
to apply for a permit for the safety of
students which never transpired then we
were asked to change location then we
were told that our table and chairs
would now be considered a public
obstruction keep in mind this is the
same school which a year ago approved a
student permit before kicking us out
anyway so we decided that we'd roll the
dice hate speech isn't real change my
mind
I are you I've been your mind change oh
sure yeah I do you disagree with me on
the outs traffic because we don't have a
table chair was taken away from us what
yeah so okay you mind scooting scooching
in but let me remind you about the
school yeah these are the cameras here
so these cameras are on you and myself
all right great
I'm not gonna bite you you can come on
in don't worry
so no I'm saying you don't worry I'm
nervous okay in the middle
everything's good yeah we're gonna like
hug it out we will afterward yeah
depends hi my name is Eric I'm from
originally from Portland Oregon okay so
I'm experienced with a lot of like
protests and things like that people
hang out of cars and punch in the face
something like that so I was one time I
was in did you hear about the May Day
protests that happened about three years
ago was the first I guess before we did
you said you are you interested in
having your mind changed I'm interested
I'm changing you changing my mind on
hate speech yes sir okay so let me kind
of establish the definition of hate
speech actually we both kind of agree on
terminologies here because we're matter
what I'm talking about is not that
people can't speak easily can and I
would discourage that yes I'm talking
about as any kind of speech that should
be differentiated legally as you see in
the UK or in my home country of Canada
okay based on its level of offense or a
quote-unquote level of oppression not a
real thing don't agree with it if you
disagree you can change my mind okay so
I think that there should be one problem
I see in schools is the issue of having
like racist thought and that sort of
thing isn't like I feel there should be
limits on what should we say and
campuses just as in the census of like
if there's someone saying like blatantly
racist things I think it'd be better
just for all involved so there isn't
that sort of hateful attitude just
because it could lead to conflict that
isn't necessary so you just don't like
it front of private campus I'm talking
in general like if someone let's say
there's a member of the KKK that starts
walking around campus and starts saying
like this is not my personal leaf but
says like white people are the superior
race I don't think that person should be
allowed to speak just simply because it
would
violence and I think only on campus I'd
say on campuses probably not
obviously there is I know there's a
Supreme Court case that allows that
speech to happen they can regulate time
and marinara are you talking about in
general you know what the government
shouldn't allow that person to speak
that way there should be legal
consequences are you just talking about
a student on campus shouldn't be able to
say I'm talking on a student on campus
because I know there is a Supreme Court
case that says Garman can regulate time
and manner I believe by on a college
campus I just don't think it's necessary
for this kind of speech to happen
because again there's not going to be a
dialogue change if someone's obviously
saying white people are the superior
race I think there does need to be some
kind of limit but obviously people do
need to have their voice heard so what I
disagree with you is are you sure that
Minds what we change your dialogue might
not be raised by a racist viewing racist
I just don't think there's any benefit
to having someone say white people are
the superior race when there's obviously
people people of color that have gone
through stripes obviously I I don't
believe that I've been oppressed before
but I think that if someone's saying
blatantly racist things there should be
limits and I don't think there's any
time like that on campus yes sir what
about in the country
I don't want to sound like a racist if I
say that but I just don't think it's I'm
trying to formulate a good argument here
sure do you mind stepping back in a
little bit because we're yeah just gonna
always come close to me here I don't
mind you I'm just a we're very limited
in where we can be as far as not you
know being obstructing the sidewalk of
course
I talk about on campus on a public
campus you know publicly funded campus
you need to provide an equal platform to
both political points of view right but
I asked you about the country at large
the contrail so again that's that's what
I'm talking about here hate speech
you're talking about legislatively
sounds to me like you think there should
be limitations on speech not obviously
colleges are gonna have their own rules
we've cut we've covered that for the
country at large I think that it should
be more of a taboo obviously if you're a
group that has race racism so how are
you changing my mind it's already a
taboo to say white people are better
than black people yes sir okay so what
what's what would you change what's the
issue that's just offensive speech but
it's protected under the First Amendment
right that's true okay I'm a little
nervous Smith that's fine that's fine I
said you said oh you already have your
mind changed so I'm gonna assume that
meant that you disagreed with something
that I'm just so I agree yeah just to
clarify so like you agree that racism is
bad and no one should say that what's
your thoughts on that no racist do I
think people should be allowed to be
racist sure why is to two but do you see
just coupled two very different
questions that's can you review that
sorry yeah you said can you do we both
agree racism is bad yes but then you in
that same sentence to ask me if I
thought it was okay should be allowed
sorry for someone to be racist if Kutcha
yes yes to both questions I think it's
bad and I think someone should be
allowed to be racist so do you think
there should be any like what is the
benefit to allowing people to be racist
is like my thing like why should the
government protect that right is my
question what is the benefit to allowing
you to say that it's bad to be racist
well I guess my viewpoint wouldn't have
just to play devil's advocate my
viewpoint I don't think would cause harm
the problem I see with racism that it it
can cause harm to people but when I'm
saying I don't think you should be
allowed to make bad comments on people's
race I feel like just from a utilitarian
standpoint is right the racist thinks
that you're causing them harm so my
point is the benefit is allowing freedom
of speech for all even speech with which
we disagree otherwise it's not freedom
of speech okay I understand otherwise
how do you how do you decide who decides
what speech is permissible and what
speech isn't I suppose well I suppose
there's two ways to do that one you have
mob rule which kind of just decides and
it makes taboos like you were saying or
you could also have the government but
the problem with there is obviously like
from your viewpoint the garment would
therefore be the deciding class from
your viewpoint is there a problem with
that
it depends obviously if there's obscene
speech if something's going to cause
harm like if you yell fire in a movie
theater you shouldn't be allowed to say
that well that's not free speech though
that's that's a call to act that shoot
is that's actually because people can be
physically harmed because you're lying
about to be you can actually yell fire
in a crowded theater you know you can
but you'll see the concept but if
there's a fire you you're helping people
right but if you lie and cause a
stampede that's your problem
that's the issues not the speech it's
the call to action gotcha so you said I
you know you presumed that I would have
a problem with the government being in
charge of permissible speech I'm asking
you since you're the one suggesting that
some speech should be allowed and some
speech shouldn't do you think there's a
problem with the government being shot
in charge of determining permissible
speech I guess it's just tricky just
because racism is such a touchy subject
and I'm sure like I'm gonna get just
like kind of y'all that just because
like what I've been saying no no but I
guess it's not really a touchy subject
everyone almost everyone in this country
agrees except for a few extremists and
there you talk about single-digit
numbers right you could probably count
them on both hands feet and maybe read
you know that your flippers how many
people are actually racist in this
country who believe that white people
are superior to black people it's not
like you're gonna get
right right I guess I guess my thing is
like maybe now that I think about it I
think that yes it's like can you say
racist things I suppose yes but my thing
is should you like should you as a
person say that no I just don't think
it's a good idea for you because we
should just respect everyone well it's
not me I didn't say anything racist of
course of course I'm saying like you
like as a pert like just a general
shorten it's like can you do this
yes should you do that probably not I'm
very good but I think the more important
question is could you be a country like
or could you be a place like Canada my
home country of cans out before a place
like the UK in Germany and legislate
speech that is offensive and put people
in jail for it well you can't right now
in the United States some people would
like us to be able to should you know
okay so they've got some more question
we agree on that
I think we do yes thank you I've watched
your show before I just wanted to be all
that I feel like thank you man I think
it was
[Music]
hi I can't really shake your hand coming
up yeah we kind of 30 months definitions
cuz we don't want to cause no stress
we're like right here yeah if that works
okay this way you might have read into
college paper one time I hate speech
another about people speaking hatefully
people can say hateful things obviously
I'm talking about any kind of speech
that's differentiated or should be
differentiated legally based on its
level of offense cause or quote-unquote
oppression yeah I'm saying the United
States the definition that's used for
example on campus quite a bit or what
was lobbed against me for example for
the rape culture isn't real I was
accused of hate speech that's not
realistic
okay if you disagree you're more than
welcome to change my mind I'm just
concerned about your definition because
like the merriam-webster definition of
hate speech is like the speech that is
hateful based on someone's like race
gender or sexuality so you're saying it
like differentiates from like the
normative definition talk about a legal
definition here in United States
okay so just the legal definition so
what someone can yes I believe I believe
that any kind of speech that would be
differentiated it out from under the
umbrella of freedom of speech doesn't
exist I don't think there's speech
offensive enough or egregious enough to
warn any kind of legislation so
unequivocably like all speech is
protected yes speech freedom of speech
okay a few questions sure go ahead
oh oh thank you I appreciate you being
so considerate i 100% agree that free
speech should be protected I'm actually
from Russia so like this is like a very
personalized issue for me I can imagine
yeah I'm from Canada
it's terrible over there - I just wonder
what about like fear-mongering like
speech that is a call to action for
violence to occur like pure teach or the
rhetoric that was perpetuated in like
the case of the pulse nightclub shooting
like hateful speech that like monger
sphere yeah so what speech are you
telling that led to the pulse nightclub
shooting perhaps religious rhetoric that
insinuated that is okay perhaps from
whom okay it was terrorists who like had
like a perpetuation of like
fear-mongering and free speech you Jim
what the post nightclub feeder himself
well certainly but like they're hitting
provocations as well that use their free
speech in order to like perpetuate
hateful rhetoric sure so let's define
hateful rhetoric okay rhetoric that is
hey I like difficult to define hateful
rhetoric is something that incites like
well just girl within I don't know okay
so how would that be defined legally
I think that anything that discriminates
against someone based on their sex
ability or disability sexual orientation
or gender can be considered hate speech
okay yeah and as something that should
be an actionable offense should be
limited or controlled or legislated by
the government your America you've heard
it like sapir-whorf right like language
constructs reality I feel like even if
speech is protected unequivocably
oftentimes that speech is misconstrued
and that rhetoric becomes violence
that's what would happen with Hitler it
was fear mongering it wasn't really
misconstrued I think Hitler was pretty
clear about what he wanted to do I think
he told the masses like I'm gonna go
kill six million Jewish people like I
don't think that was like his initial
message it was his initial message you
know he eased into it but I think to
compare Hitler's for example his
rhetoric and being a part of you know
the National Socialist Party of Germany
comparing that to someone who might say
something that someone could
misconstrued as hateful and uses
inspiration to commit an act of violence
is not at all the same so I guess you
know used to get some questions for me
what would be an example of speech that
you think should be controlled or
legislated by the government if someone
tweets out you should go kill this
person because they're gay I certainly
believe that they of course free speech
no okay no we already have laws in the
books for that and that's because an
active call to violence it's the action
so for example you could say I hate
steven crowder that's fine say you could
say yeah you could say I hope Steven
credit gets I don't know gets stabbed
with a pitchfork okay that's probably
fine I hope he gets run over by a car
you can't say go run over steven crowder
with a car or I'll pay five hundred
dollars to someone who runs over steven
crowder with a car it's the call to
action they're already laws in the book
well the law drives draws a line at an
active call to action okay in 2016
during the election at TCU people went
around on bulletin boards writing the
three-fifths compromise needs to come
back would that be considered the what
was the three-fifths compromise needs to
come back okay what about the considered
hate speech like would you protect that
what would I protect that well I don't
know what your rule is on shocking or
painting or whatever it is but don't
think those students should go to jail
do I think they should know I also think
I wasn't there wasn't a TCU that there
were people talk about the eight words
I'm some of the neo-nazi or time ago
that 8888 okay let's party poop swastika
which is proven to be a hoax so uh no I
think I think people should be able to
say things that are wildly offensive
whether it's racist whether it's you
know quote-unquote homophobic I think I
have no problem with it doesn't mean I
agree with the point of view I think it
should be freedom of speech for all I
believe in the First Amendment or then
you have to determine for me what the
line is where's the line I guess because
I you know I noticed you have a lot of
questions want to ask you questions you
answer with a question where's the
where's a line for freedom of speech
right
what do you disagree with me on what do
you want to change my mind though I
think that certain expressions of free
speech lead to violent actions occurring
okay I think that it's very hard to say
that there's no correlation there you
know I didn't say there's no correlation
okay but then how do we exist in a
society when we're allowing people to
like directly influence or like
indirectly violent actions well there's
a very big difference isn't there please
explain we just what you just said
directly or indirectly directly or
indirectly yeah so directly so violence
is like so eagle so if you're calling
but what if like your speech the
rhetoric that you're putting out to the
public is the reason that eventually a
hate crime occurs like shooting should
be held to some kind of penalty for that
so could you give me an example of what
kind of speech because again I gave an
example of direct so I think this is
important because as you said you're in
the debate team yes right so direct and
indirect are important right there there
antonyms right so direct like I said
would be kill steven crowder with your
car okay will be an example of indirect
hate speech that would lead someone to
commit violence that you believe needs
to be controlled or legislated if
someone is constantly tweeting out like
racial slurs like well I was gonna
trying to go with the simcard example
but let's say okay let's say I'll say
this someone says black people are
inferior to white people or someone says
black people are inferior to Asians or
Russians whatever it's take your pick
okay and then someone later on
that's it that's the sound of that's the
sound of losing an argument so someone
said something racist down the line
someone says I was inspired by this
racist statement to commit an act of
violence
that was incorrect that correlation is
what's dangerous I think because
language constructs reality because what
people are putting out there is
oftentimes the reason why certain
actions occur I think that there's not
necessarily limitations or censorship I
don't believe in that at all but there
has to like be a line drawn at some
point well if there's if you're not did
you just say that you don't support any
kind of legislation or censorship but
there does need to be a line I certainly
don't think that like the government
should be interfering and what's put out
in the media but I think that's
different than what someone's like
tweeting out if someone's tweeting out
this violent like I'm trying to like
draw a distinction but I don't think
you're getting me that's fine no I think
I am getting you just said you don't
supporting kind of legislation or
censorship but there does need to be a
line drawn so what do you mean by line
like decency humanity I think that agree
yeah I agree
so I don't understand what you're
arguing then I'm talking about hate
speech as legislation as an exists in my
home country of Canada you said Russia
so we just talked about this with I
believe Nick was his name in Canada you
can be fined for hate speech I have a
friend as a comedian who was put before
human rights tribunal for telling a joke
in the UK it's over 3,000 people per
year alone just recently a girl was a
charged with a hate crime for posting
Snoop Dogg lyrics on her Facebook page
because it included the n-word I'm sure
you're familiar with count dank you love
the dog for the Nazi salute right so in
other countries you can be charged
convicted for criminal behavior based on
speech we have the First Amendment so we
don't have that here the term hate
speech in those countries is used to
create that line which by the way that
authority has been granted to their
government in the United States
thankfully we don't hate speech doesn't
mean anything it's in a legal
terminology lots of people would like to
change that that's what I'm talking
about but if you'd seem it seems like we
agree if you don't believe that the
government should have any role in
legislating speech at all and you're
good with them then I think we agreed no
okay so if someone were to draw a
swastika in our Commons is their speech
protected well hold on a second here
speech is given from freedom of
expression people express their speech
through differently no no legally
they're not the same thing so that being
said the campus of course can do what
they want especially it's a private
campus they can do what they want just
like a private business can do it the
one I saw you brought up Twitter earlier
but freedom of expression is actually
not in the Constitution anywhere freedom
of speech is as a reason for that is as
you said people express themselves in
different ways some people can express
themselves in ways that are very
destructive physically as a matter of
fact matter are given if you look at
artists they actually often do things
that are physically damaging if not to
their own bodies to other people speech
by itself speech is not destructive to
that degree that's why freedom of speech
is protected and the First Amendment of
the Constitution and freedom of
expression isn't so I'd like to give a
conversation to speech because every
time with the written word yeah I just
which is important to cadets action
important elimination because of libel
versus slander but yeah so sounds like
you agree that speech shouldn't have any
limitations the government shouldn't
disagree on is that I believe that
oftentimes hate speech can be the
catalyst towards violent crimes and
violent actions and acts of hatred I
don't think we're agreeing on that point
okay so how do you how do you fix it
then perhaps speak in a culture where
hate speech look isn't normalized I feel
like hateful rhetoric has become
normalized recently like especially like
in the status quo you believe that like
they can put anything out there or say
anything without any let's see there oh
you keep kind of cutting yourself their
punishment would me punishment by yeah I
mean you're you're you're in a debate
right what is it what is punishment mean
it depends like the body of like
okay but the person who would be
administering punishment would have to
be in a position of authority
perhaps winter BOTS were regulating
Twitter well that's more aware time in a
colloquy Nicole but we're done with
actual punishment right he said without
punishment punishment would have to come
from some authority figure right someone
has the authority to punish somebody
else so that would be I think that
you're Metro sizing hate speech to
something that it's like
I don't by your definition that it's
only like what can't be legislated as it
is in Canada like hateful rhetoric it is
yes I said that right at the outset
people say hateful things but you said
that they should be allowed to what
should be like what in the status quo is
like legislated or like laws or police
action as far as what as what we're
talking about today hate speech as its
lobbed on this campus for example let me
give you kind of a jumping-off one the
reason we're back here I was accused of
hate speech okay or the last time I was
here on this campus where the sense that
rape culture is a myth well change my
mind I will actually say that I like
entirely disagree I think you have a
right to be here you have a right to
like engage in peaceful discourse with
students I think it's kind of ridiculous
when they start screaming and crying and
can't control their emotions I
appreciate it thank you but a lot of
people said that was hate speech okay so
it again it serves to eliminate that
many different people have different
lines of what determines hate speech
that's why it has to come down to some
kind of a legally identifiable
definition in the United States it
doesn't exist okay I agree with that I'm
Pro hate speech not existing as a legal
term I'm Pro First Amendment I am never
going to disagree with anyone who says
that some people speak hatefully now you
keep going back to sometimes people
speak hatefully or they use hateful
rhetoric and someone misconstrues that
to commit an act of violence I of course
don't think that's protected so you
think that like religious leaders like
let's say like Ayatollah Khomeini who
constantly goes like death to America
and consoling perpetuates rhetoric that
like Americans are like Western invaders
who are horrible and deserve to die
because his speech protected if Iran
didn't have such terrible loss well I
think it I was gonna say maybe more fair
to use an American example like Louis
Farrakhan okay do you think that his
speeches protects [ __ ] is protected so
when people like religious zealots go
out and commit crimes like in the name
of their religion like McGarry is
incited that violence should continue to
be protected
yes now unless it's a direct call to
action for example Louis Farrakhan goes
out and he's called jewel Jews
everything I think from the white devil
to mongrels he's been very anti-semitic
he has the right to speak freely
absolutely now if someone goes out and
says I killed somebody or I beat up a
Jewish person at a pro Palestinian
protest because Farrakhan called them
white Devils Farrakhan speech is still
protected do you think it's not I just I
certainly believe that if a nation isn't
doing anything to stop like the rhetoric
that's inciting these horrible like
shootings at synagogues like perhaps the
person who like did the shooting or
heard like some inflammatory or sorry if
your mom's rhetoric like in it I just
like don't understand how we continue to
allow this type of like rhetoric and
speech to exist in the status quo and we
know that it directly correlates and
directly creates and incites violence
like how do we as a country like well
first up we don't we don't know that it
directly correlates to violence what we
do know is that if you look at every
single major free rights human rights
movement in the United States started
with speech I started with speech from
minority groups whether you're talking
about civil rights movement the 60s
whether you're talking about even more
recently where people would use you okay
marriage is an example starts with
people in the minority who are afforded
the same rights as those in the majority
to speak freely I believe that those
minorities should be afforded the exact
same liberties and freedom as anyone is
in a majority regardless of how many
electoral votes they represent so I
think it's if it comes down to what
you're talking about you said we
continue to allow that's actually
interesting language to me
because we don't allow anything
I mean if we believe in the First
Amendment right it's we don't grant
basic human rights birth rights okay the
term inalienable I'm sure you're
familiar with means these rights come
from God God yeah yeah let's just say
the universe let's see if you don't
believe in God right the point is
they're not granted by government
they're not granted by a Supreme Court
not granted by voters it's a birthright
so when you say we allow this hateful
rhetoric yeah
we're not allowing anything people are
speaking freely and we can't interfere
with that that's what our basis of laws
is a fundamental do you have any like if
I were to bring to you a study I don't
have it but I have studies on both sides
that show everything exists if I were to
bring you a study that said that there's
a direct correlation between hateful
speech and violent crime yeah you would
say that nothing needs to be done and we
can just allow that continued to exist
in the status quo I would ask you what
do you think needs to be done let's say
you have that study and it says hateful
speech first up we need to define
hateful speech it's something offensive
I think hateful speech like the
definitions that I've seen from like
Marian Webster Oxford like directly
state that this hateful speech is like
targeted towards minority groups like
normally like that's what this defined
us okay so can be like conservatives on
college campus yeah I agree
okay does it include for example someone
posting Snoop Dogg lyrics to their
Facebook that's where I think that
there's a problem I think that people
misconstrue what hate speech is like
when it's truly like ridiculous like
people like take it out of hand people
can't control their emotions people are
enraged by it like stupidity honor right
yeah but you understand for example
would count dang Fela though right but
these are the most modern examples yeah
right the more severe example like you
mentioned being from Russia would be
Stalin would be Adolf Hitler so the best
examples we have have still resulted in
unintended consequences and gross
violations of human rights and they're
on the freedom of speech there is no
good example okay so do you think it
would be a slippery slope of the United
States implemented laws for hate speech
I think it's the only place left that
actually well first up it's a place that
created freedom of speech as we know it
it's the only place that exists I think
that's a good thing and I don't think
that should change and I don't think
that that should change regardless of
whether there's a study or not that
would say someone says something hateful
and there's an increase in violent crime
let's go with you on that and say that
that's true I think that the good far
outweighs the bad I think there's a far
greater risk in limiting people's
individual freedoms and granting the
authority as to what's permissible in
the religion as it relates to speech to
a centralized government so do you think
the good speech can outweigh that bad
speech in like those violent crimes like
I'm trying to like understand like I
think I think that's the best way to
combat hateful speech she has is good
speech I just don't think the
government's role to step in and say
which speeches what kind of speech is
permissible it sounds like you agree I
do think that I'm like I'm drawing a
distinction nuts to like I truly believe
that there's a correlation between the
two and if we're not doing anything even
as a people or as a government
legislating like some okay okay so there
we go this is what kind of debate going
on around around right now it comes down
to the truth right you said as a people
we need to be doing some kind of
legislating what legislating and what
speech is worthy of legislating I don't
think we have a good country to take an
example off of I don't think anyone's
done it properly I think that they've
taken it either too far like the count
thank you lot example that you continue
to bring out but good what I don't get I
brought up several examples you're gonna
cycle through them again okay good cuz
the bay you're misrepresenting me there
but go ahead continue I just I don't
believe that we can exist in a country
that respects democracy and equality if
we're allowing people to continue
putting forth hateful rhetoric that
incites violence so again I ask you what
legislation you've already said you are
okay what you think would be a superior
choice to give the authority over to the
government to legislate speech how so
well certainly we don't have like a
really great definition of hate speech
thus far like I mean like hateful
rhetoric is okay so you decide I'm not
the one advocating legislation right you
are so you define it we should legislate
Blanc kind of speech that we're not
right now
I think speech that has the ability to
incite violence but again how do you
weigh that I think that it's a tricky
balancing act that has occurred with us
I am NOT a politician nor am i part of
the legislature in the United States so
I wouldn't be able to come up with like
but you're willing to give that power
over to the legislature if they properly
implement laws okay how would they
properly implement no one here I
certainly don't think this is North
Korea I don't think it should be
imprisoned for like exercising their
free speech but I do think that we need
to draw a line in order to
these like incendiary forms of speech
from perpetuating throughout the masses
I guess I'm still what what is that line
what is that line yeah what is that line
that's very difficult to say and now I
understand why you say that hate speech
isn't real there's no real definition of
hate speech that exists in the status
quo that can be applicable to like
legislate and as you acknowledge
everywhere else that it has been
applicable has been terrible from the
extreme examples to the most modern
examples you just said no country that
is basically incorporated what you're
proposing is sort of vague legislation
right now no country has done it well so
you said the United Kingdom had 3,000
about 3,000 per year okay do you have a
statistic showing how many of those are
like righteously like deserved well I
don't think that any of them are
righteously deserved outside of actual
threats of physical violence
in other words so again that's what's
most important I don't think any any
example in Canada the comedian being
fined or put Freeman rice tribunal is
okay but I'm not the one proposing
legislation I'm good with the First
Amendment you're the one who is
proposing a change but you can't draw
the line as to what should be
permissible and what isn't permissible
but you're willing to give that huge
swath of control over to the government
and I'm sure that we can both agree
that's a very dangerous idea let's say
we had an epic soccer scene like who was
gonna take charge of hate speech like
the best of the best most intellectual
people who were like defined hate speech
or something that's like parametric eyes
to be accurate and like functional would
you be okay with that who picks the
group I don't know we take a test
everyone takes a test and the smartest
the smartest 2% of the nation is like
taken and they get to decide what is
hate speech and what watch me put forth
so do we
this is based on the premise that the
smartest 2% of the population would be
the most effective at preserving laws
and the liberty of we're creating laws
it's creating
I don't agree I don't agree that only
that only the top 2% of intellectuals
should be in control of birthrights the
people's right to freedom of speech so I
want to make sure they understand
correctly we disagree I appreciate being
respected we disagree on the idea that
there should be some legislation on
speech they're not exactly clear as to
what that line is but you're willing to
give that you're willing to give that
roll over to not necessarily the
government but an appointed Board of the
top 2% of America but I do we should
take people for like highly intellectual
and no on the subject like communication
scholars sociologists like people who
directly study humanity and
communication yeah when we say the
founding fathers were intelligent I do
think the founding fathers are
intelligent I moved to this country for
a reason but I do also think that they
were part of the elite and perhaps
didn't know what it's like to be part of
a minority group what can you name me a
tool I guess it has been used more by
minority group to improve their lives
and then the freedom of speech freedom
of speech has certainly helped them but
it's also like harm to them when them
like majority uses it against them okay
yeah so again but you do understand if
you're offering that power over to a
government right you've mentioned the
matter for a constitutional republic but
it would be even worse with our
democracy right now you have mob rule if
you have people who are in charge of
determining speech laws you say that's
even more difficult then you have for
example Nazi Germany yeah not
necessarily I wouldn't say majority
don't want to miss you the term but a
plurality right at that point for
example in Canada we don't have a
two-party system so you can have someone
elected means 30% of the vote a
plurality of the people who believe in
one particular set of they believe one
world view yeah and they can implement
that on minorities as you saw in Russia
as you see in the Castro regime that's
dangerous so allowing anyone to
determine what basic fundamental human
rights are permissible or allowed to use
your language it's just it's
antithetical to the founding fathers
view of government that's the whole
reason for freedom speech is so that the
majority as mob rule can't infringe on
the rights of a minority and I think the
same freedom of speech should be
afforded to everybody whether the
majority of minority because it's
ever-changing we both gonna grow now
absolutely yeah that's my point of view
and it just it hasn't changed I think I
agree with you on most things
except for great representation of our
campus I do appreciate the respectful
discourse I think we agree on like a lot
but also disagree on like very little I
don't think I'm gonna change your mind
but I do think that this was like good
discourse
before we move on to seconds to plug mug
club what is my club well it's what
allows us to continue producing these
videos to the amount of ization and
shadow banning not only do you get this
wonderful hand-painted hand edge mug and
get support the kind of content that
you're watching right now but you get to
watch the 1-hour daily show as well as
all of the contents available at CR TV
bladder excited calm slash mug club on
with the show
now it's important to note that the
point of change my mind is not to debate
rather to rationalize one's position and
sometimes common ground just is nowhere
to be found so you would be okay with
restricting freedom of speech you would
be okay with restricting or increasing
creating actually speech laws if that
were voted on by the masses if the
masses want it absolutely more on that
in a second but sometimes you find
kinships in the most surprising of
places all right my hands are icicles
what was your name my name is Felicia
Felicia all right so you know at the end
of this interview it's gonna be an easy
Landers bye Felicia sorry it was my
water I did not spit I swear to you I
moved it that's what happened no no I
just wanted to regret I wanted to read
it we're gonna get to that bye Felicia
sooner than I thought oh no I doesn't
even bother me anymore
I bet you people do that all the time
because it's like as soon as you show
somebody that something bothers you them
they're just kind of troll you I believe
which is why you keep coming here right
no it's not the troll we've had really
productive conversation so no we're not
we're not here so you just mentioned
that your boyfriend was a fan big fan
biggest rompers he loves Steve he asked
me to bring a Steve King sign really for
y'all who don't know he's the
congressman
I was there why would he ask you to
bring that because he looks anyway yeah
but you were and you said that you've
never been more disappointed I've never
been more disappointed and embarrassed
by the people who claim to share my same
values how so at some point when you
disagree with somebody or you don't like
what they're saying that doesn't mean
that you just have to start attacking
them you have to figure out a way to
intellectually come up with your
argument stop putting shame all over
what people work tirelessly for to make
life better yeah at the end I mean
that's like from the left and the right
everyone so yeah I guess I would relate
kind of to today's topic where you see a
lot of people on the left or did you see
a lot of people to campaign going I
can't believe that this person said that
should be hate speech you know I can't
remember what sort of non-disclosures I
signed at the beginning of the car you
were disappointed but I was just as far
as the specifics as far as our weekly
communication calls we're all we were
told to do was to attack Donald Trump
weekly on communication calls as to
pivot away from whatever controversy
Hillary found herself in yeah
so from there you can just see it
seeping down I'm into teenagers alike
it's just it's embarrassing I'm ashamed
well don't be ashamed you don't have any
shame done being honest hate the fact
that I want to be able to call myself a
progressive or a liberal or a Democrat
but all that happens is people will just
assume that I'm gonna come over here and
scream or spit or rip or cry because I
don't like what somebody says right hate
speech is just speech it's mean yes
right there are social norms that we
should try to abide by a decency just
don't go around calling people bad words
right right doesn't mean that you should
get thrown in jail for it it doesn't
mean the government should legislative
there's a soul which is a whole nother
you know right a couple call-to-action
exact so it's interesting you say that
you you know your progressive kind of
more liberal I want of it so you would
like to be able to but because you're so
concerned with your insane on this on
that but the fact that that label is now
associated with something so radical at
some point you can try to be so
inclusive so this or so that but you
just exclude people I was an active
member and donor of our County
Democratic Party and at some point I
didn't agree with Nancy Pelosi didn't
want to go see her I think she's a
terrible choice for Speaker of the House
yeah and I was told just to go to a
Republican meeting really yes so at this
point that's crazy I mean I would have
thought that most Democrats don't really
like Nancy Pelosi she's just a necessary
evil you know but you're not supposed to
go and are you some of the woman was
denied communion the previous Pope so
even the pre I think what the previous
Pope was like so you got flack for that
they said well you might he'll be a
Republican is that does that sort of
tell you that maybe maybe the current
democratic party like they're more
narrow-minded then I would say
generalize it that hard I really and
just I'm really against the
generalizations I really hate the
concepts like I said like why I don't
want to be generalized in this group of
people that I but they kicked you out
yeah I know but my boyfriend Connor you
said hi to says I'm in an identified
entity crisis I think so a little bit
all right let me ask you this cuz you
seem like you're supportive of the First
Amendment of freedom of speech I'm a
supporter of all five articles of the
Constitution really mm-hmm okay so then
you right away or that disqualifies you
from being a modern democratic okay let
me ask you this who who would you feel
on a national platform and the
Democratic Party represents your values
as they relate to things like freedom of
speech things like individual liberty
and it seems like you're against
identity politics obviously it's hard
for me to say you know this one person
dan I'm taller I've got moose height so
I can stand here as I help you know okay
I can't name one person on the
Democratic Party that I would want to
you know stand there and lead us to
victory in 2020 name one person I think
that if Amy clothes are out of Minnesota
anybody senator from Minnesota would
denounce Keith Ellison just as you know
everybody traveling that was an odd kind
of an odd spell with a me too and then
Keith Ellison okay it's hard to justify
that in an argument but I would say
currently she's kind of my favorite
centrist
a centrist as you can get Democrats okay
I think that if she could just denounce
Keith Ellison I'm waiting kind of
worried maybe she didn't do it because
she was worried about her reelection so
now she's been reelected hopefully she
can come out and okay all right well
thank well I appreciate it wasn't even I
forgot to do that I'm not gonna say that
bye Felisha thing I appreciate you
standing here in discussing Felicia now
in contrast to that some folks these
events just can't be reasoned with want
to take up all of the time at the podium
and just will not let you go even after
the conversation has ended multiple
times I appreciate that you go on for a
while but let me kind of laser it on
this question so you would be okay with
restricting freedom of speech would be
okay with restricting or increasing
creating actually speech laws if that
were voted on by the masses if the
masses want it absolutely really if the
masses and again I'm wanting legitimate
masses what the bulk of the people in
the country want yes I absolutely would
and I'm gonna use actually I'm actually
gonna use conservative logic for a
second and conservatives frequently say
if you don't like it leave I'm not
saying if you don't like it leave but
I'm saying that the typical logic is if
the people if the multiple of people
want something from both sides typically
that's what everyone says should happen
no
give me an example the first amendment
again doesn't matter if you don't get to
vote on it humans still chose that
humans still wrote the first amendment
and said yeah matters and it's the only
country that has the first amendment
until a human that said that it's lost
excuse me humans that said that and
humans were the ones who said this law
is in a level as you said this law is
this right it's given to us no matter
what humans still sent that in humans to
absolutely have the right to change I
think if you're just saying that all
laws should just be determined by Mat by
mob rule particularly freedom of speech
I think it's really a scary thought
honestly I disagree with you I will
qualify guess what Donald Trump Mike
Pence and a Senate majority right now
can determine that what you say is hate
speech I will fly down for a second I
will qualify that not just straight up
mob rule but mob rule an actual evidence
based science critical thinking things
like that yeah no I disagree I disagree
I don't think that people should be okay
with someone taking it away as long as
it's taking away things that hurt people
as long as it's taking away things that
we as a science know does lead to lower
well-being does eventually incite
hostility and eventual hate crime which
I know hate crime pastries not the same
thing but does eventually lead to that
that does become a problem and that's
where the discussion needs to happen is
what speech is protected what speech is
not protected when it does lead to
problems that does affect the prosperity
of people and the prosperity of our
country yeah I think it's pretty I think
you've just laid out a very subjective
definition and left it in the hands of
not only mob rule but then eventually
bureaucrats to determine a fundamental
human right I just don't agree with you
but I appreciate taking the time yeah
thank you for chatting with me thank you
man unfortunately you've not used my
mind I've not changed your mind my goal
wasn't to change your mind your goal is
to change mine a mock mob rule I just
rule of the masses and critical thinking
you don't get totally you don't get to
vote on a fundamental human right we
chose the rights we can choose to get
rid of there you go well I guess that's
that's a very different worldview and
I'm not okay with anyone removing your
rights at all okay with anyone stepping
in and saying you don't have the right
to believe what you believe or speak
freely but you're okay with someone
walking in and telling some what they
can and can't say that's terrible what
I'm not and as a sociology major it is
it is striking to me
I'm the geology mate I'm psychology
psychology okay so let's go with
psychology as a psychology major do you
not see the grave risk the much more
grave risk in centralizing the power to
a government or allowing it to be tossed
to a vote every single time because that
changes that cultural fabric a
fundamental right like freedom of speech
as opposed to allowing it allowing
people to speak freely do you not see
that historically the mini-vac universe
question before I mentioned the
psychology sociology I'd like to talk
about that before I do mention that
really well I don't know could you
remind me of it so I can make sure I'm
responding correctly I just the question
before I miss yes I don't know what the
question was so my question is this I'm
surprised that's when you say you're a
PhD candidate so you're obviously a very
smart person how you don't see the grave
risk the much more I mean historically
just the the unbelievable risk of
violence associated with centralizing
the power and who determines speech and
what's permissible you know it could
backfire
you really can't it always has it's
never not but a [ __ ] is never not I
would like to see evidence for that can
you point me to any single country that
is restrictive sorry okay can you give
me just Nazi German a Soviet Russia
Castro chikka very regimes current UK
Canada Maoist China need I go on
absolutely you said every country every
can you provide an example with one
country I'm sorry but you said every
this is every single country that has
limited freedom of speech has it has
resulted in a net loss argument this is
on you for that you were the one okay
you said okay let me put it this way
every single country that's not the
United States it's worse than the United
States and in relation to free speech
please give me an actual citation to
back up your claim I not know a citation
please
that is a scholarly source that you were
going to be able to rely on that is
actually done the research for this okay
so you would say that Nazi Germany
Soviet Russia Maoist China Che Guevera
Castro regime
Canada where people I'm just can't
listen I can't go through every single
country come on I'm not I'm just asking
you forgive me a scholarly source that
says that okay I don't have a scholarly
source with me right now saying that
Nazi Germany is worse off with speech
laws than United States what'd I say
there's going to take my word for and
exactly what I said was there are plenty
of examples
doesn't work you're absolutely right I
don't disagree meetings we can possibly
get to the point where a camera and we
need to keep trying that doesn't because
it hasn't worked one
we don't give one well you asked me if
resources one country that has better
net results for human freedom and human
rights by restricting speech what's your
source one okay thank you very much I
appreciate it brother
thank you so much hopefully once we put
in that one example that'll be great oh
well they can't all be gems by the way
notice anything even though he returned
to TCU where they screeched and warned
about the perils of this program the
students were by and large peaceful
civil engage and most left surprisingly
on dramatised even more we couldn't walk
through campus without students both
left and right expressing their
appreciation for our for your efforts
really which begs a question our
students really too far gone beyond
saving or is it just the loudest voice
is amplified by the far left
administrators who've made us think that
to be so this video watch another one of
our videos or subscribe hit the
notification bell those don't really
mean anything anymore today in youtube I
would say hit a like was a thumbs up but
that might be gone or comment below but
that most likely will be censored so
bookmark the page of course if you're
using Google Chrome they'll find a way
to [ __ ] with your bookmark so just join
up at Lara's credit comm slash mug Club
that's lighter with credit comm slash
mug Club you get a hand at Remagen you
get access to the full daily one-hour
show and you're not beholden to Susan
Wojcicki slash Clint Howard